we're going to prove this result within
number theory that
looks very very simple and in fact the
proof itself is very few lines it's not
going to look like it's a lot of work
however there are some really important
concepts underneath how we prove this
which
are probably what you might struggle
with when you're trying to think of a
way to actually
make a path through this question so
let's read the question
and then we're going to have a go at
number one laying some helpful
foundations
um trying to really deeply understand
some things some ideas you've been doing
for a long time but
in the language of the nature of proof
and then we'll do the proof itself
prove that an integer is the sum of
seven consecutive
integers if and only if it is divisible
by seven now uh if you have a look at
this uh clearly there are some important
pieces that are worth noting
uh we're going to have to work with the
sum of seven consecutive integers and we
can phrase that
in algebraic terms we have a
divisibility issue here right so
divisible by 7 we also know how to
explain that
or articulate that and express that in
algebraic terms it's just a multiple of
seven so seven times some integer
but i actually think the weirdest and
trickiest part of this
is kind of hiding in plain sight it's
this part here
if and only if you might recall this as
the language that we use
when two statements are equivalent which
is to say
one statement implies uh the the sort of
antecedent clause implies the consequent
clause
and also the same is true in reverse uh
the converse is also true that the
if you know the uh consequent clause
that also implies
the antecedent clause so i guess we
would say that we could use this
uh you know double-sided arrow here
right that the
the implication is true and it's
converse is true
so not only is the sum of seven
consecutive integers going to be divided
by seven
but you can also say any number
divisible by seven
can be written as the sum of seven
consecutive integers which is
much less obvious now in order to get at
this
what i want you to recall is that
actually you've been dealing with
equivalent statements
um if and only if implication and
converse are also true
you've been dealing with them for years
and years which just never clothed them
in this formal
language of proof let me give you an
example to try and convince you of this
if i gave you let's just go with green
because that's what we're trying to
consider here
if i gave you some random algebraic
statement like m plus one
on three equals four uh instinctively
you're probably looking at this and
thinking
well this is not a hard thing to solve
i'm just going to
try and make n the subject so the most
obvious first thing to do is multiply
by 3. so if you did that you would write
this
now here's what i want to get across to
you right these are two different
statements
n plus 1 on 3 equals 4. it's a
conditional statement by the way it
isn't true for all values of n it's only
true for a certain value of n namely 11.
but what you then write underneath this
is its own
statement which is related to the
previous one not just by
arithmetic it's also related by logic
can you
see that these two statements here are
actually
what we now call equivalent statements
if this is true if this is true that n
plus 1 and 3 equals 4
it necessarily follows that n plus 1
equals 12.
but the converse is also true there's no
reason why you can't go in reverse
n plus 1 equals 12 also implies that n
plus 1 on 3 equals 4 i just have to
divide both sides by 3.
what i guess i'm trying to say here is
that i don't know in 99.9999
of all of the working in mathematical
problems you've been doing
whenever you've written an equation and
then written the next thing by doing
some kind of operation to both sides
you've almost always been writing an if
and only if statement you've just never
articulated
now in a small number of cases this
isn't always true
and now we have the language to explain
what's going on for example
if i said to you and just stay with me
even though this is like
mind-numbingly simple just for the sake
of illustration suppose i said to you
that x equals 5
right does this imply
can i say that this statement will mean
that x squared equals
25 just think about it for a minute
and the answer is yes of course it must
if x equals 5 when you square it
there's nothing else you can possibly
get it has to be 25
but this is not an if and only if
statement this is why we draw attention
to it when we're first dealing with
quadratic equations that kind of thing
if i gave you instead and this is a i'm
going to treat this as a separate
example
x squared equals 25 does that
imply that x equals 5.
is the converse of example 2 true and
the answer is
no it is not true because x squared
equals 25 implies
there's another possibility x can of
course also
equal negative five there's the negative
case here right
so i guess what i'm trying to say here
is i'm trying to highlight that
for some operations like say squaring
and
cancelling as well is is in a similar
boat right
you have to be very careful with the
direction of your implication and this
is something that
students famously get confused by when
we're thinking about square roots
why do we only take the positive value
and not take both and it has to do with
the the asymmetry of this
um of this logical statement okay this
is one of those very few examples
where one equation is not true if and
only if
it's related you know sort of i i felt
like i did the same thing to both sides
i just squared it right
this is one of the unusual cases under
most circumstances
you know a lot of the work that we've
been doing will fall under this case and
if only if
so what this means is how do i prove an
if and only if statement
if i can do it through a series of
fairly straightforward
if this is true algebraically this
equals this then
applying an operation both sides you
know preserves
that that truth statement then i've
arrived at my if and only if so
now i've laid a foundation that
basically writing equations that flow on
one necessarily from the other
is equivalent logically to saying a
string of if and only if statements
now i'm ready to actually prove this
question here's how i'm going to go
about it
proof let the uh
smallest of the seven integers let the
smallest integer equal
n minus three where because i'm in
integer n i need to specify that m is an
integer
to make n minus 3 an integer now this
might seem
very random but it's not going to be in
about
60 seconds if the smallest integer is n
minus 3 then it is not difficult to
write the sum
of the seven consecutive integers that
start with n minus three i can say
therefore
the sum of seven consecutive integers
will equal what and the answer is
equals i start with n minus three let me
put a bracket set of brackets around it
to make it clear that that's one number
and then the next one along will be n
minus two i'm just incrementing
by one then n minus one and then evan
and there's my fourth number then i keep
going
in my adding one pattern there's my uh
fifth number here comes the sixth one
and then here comes
the seventh one all right so now you can
see why i hope
i started with n minus three because i
want to get some cancelling happening
right this minus 3 is going to cancel
with this plus 3.
this minus 2 is going to cancel with
this plus 2 you get
the idea so what am i getting it's just
going to be n plus n
plus n i've got seven of these things
because they're seven
consecutive integers so that's clearly
equal
to 7n but i said
n is an integer so therefore 7n
must be 7 times an integer that's a
multiple
of 7. i.e a multiple of seven
therefore the sum of seven consecutive
integers
must be divisible by seven because all
multiples of seven by definition are
and because what i've done is i've gone
through these
equations not doing anything dramatic
not doing any like squaring or taking
square roots
that would mark with the direction of my
um implication
every line here is an if and only if
statement
so the sum of seven consecutive integers
equals this
if and only if it's equal to this which
it is if and only if it's equal to this
and so if it's a multiple of seven
then the implication also runs in the
reverse direction i can just climb back
up my ladder
and i've proven that if it's divisible
by seven it's also for the sum
of seven consecutive integers so i hope
that makes sense
um i know it might be a bit obvious to
think about such a simple proof and to
think about it in this deep way
that's kind of why we're we're doing
this topic the nature of proof we're
really trying to dig
deep down into the foundations of why
the things that we say are true
actually are reliable